hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
for monday monday yeah monday
december 14th 2020 what's going on how
are yeah oh my god there's only
[ __ ] i don't know
uh 12 13
[Music]
12 11. what no
there's ten more shopping days till
christmas god that took me a long time
to figure that out
ten more it's only ten more days to shop
can you [ __ ] believe there's people
out there other than children
actually asking for something for
christmas this year
what would you like for christmas uh for
this [ __ ] pandemic to be over
so everybody can go back to work earn a
wage
and and feel like they're going to be
all right over the next [ __ ] two
weeks
what would you like um well i was
watching keeping up with the kardashians
and they had this chocolate colored
[ __ ] bag
that i just it to die for it just
brought out
kim's eyes and i feel if i get it
in some small way i'm as pretty as her
the [ __ ] is wrong with people you know
there's broads out there right now
oh there's a whole bunch of them they
actually got the [ __ ] balls to ask
for a ring for christmas
it's like well do you want me to [ __ ]
make it
you know i'll go take one of those
[ __ ] shower curtain rings off the the
thing you know
i'll stick it on your thumb
um yeah people i should have said this
like
six weeks eight weeks ago
what do you want for christmas i don't i
don't need anything okay let's let's get
the kids something if we don't have any
kids
let's just go to the [ __ ] olive
garden i'm sorry order out or sit
outside
you know next in our car with the
sunroof closed
that's christmas caroling with masks on
the truck
um yeah but you know what the vaccine is
here and i
understand that a lot of people don't
want to take it i get it
i get it i understand that you know
especially uh let's see here
let's see government
[Music]
uh
all right let's see if i can do this
right the oh that
to gus tusk tusky study
tuskegee sorry it's called the tuskegee
study of
untreated syphilis in the negro male
that was the name of the study study
initially involved 600 black men
399 with syphilis 201 who did not have
the they just gave it to him
so i understand them not wanting to say
i understand if you're a [ __ ]
seri uh serial killer a [ __ ] white
person why did i just say
i'm conspiracy theorist
not a serial killer all right here we go
the study began
study begins in 1932 the public health
service working with the
tuskegee institute began a study to
record the natural history of syphilis
in hopes of justifying treatment
programs
for blacks it was called the tuskegee
study of untreated syphilis in the negro
male the study involved
600 black men 399 with syphilis 201 who
did not have the disease the study was
conducted without the benefit of the
patient's informed consent
researchers told the men that they were
being treated for bad blood
a local term used to describe several
ailments including syphilis anemia and
fatigue
in truth they did not receive the proper
treatment needed to cure their illness
in exchange for taking part in the study
the men received free
medical exams free meals and burial
insurance
oh my god although originally projected
to last six months the study actually
went on for 40 years
what went wrong gee what went wrong july
1972 an associated press story about the
tuskegee study caused a public health
outcry that led to the assistant
secretary for health and scientific
affairs to appoint the ad hoc
advisory panel to review the study the
panel had nine members from
the field of medicine law labor the
panel found that the men
had agreed freely to be examined treated
however there was no evidence that the
researchers had informed them nobody
said i want that [ __ ]
all right so i get black people not
doing it
and i understand why people who are into
conspiracy theory or worked in the
military
not trusting the government i understand
that
but if you're a perfectly good middle
class [ __ ] white guy like
me you [ __ ] sign me up you know what
guys i'll take the hit
and all you got to do is just listen to
the podcast every week
and if i start sounding a little droopy
a little syphilisy or some whatever the
[ __ ] they might do then then you know
it's not good all right maybe i'll have
a safe word
uh i don't know we shall see um
but getting back to the other [ __ ] you
know people asking for big gifts ladies
people asking for big gifts women people
the people
out there asking for big gifts
females um yeah what are you doing
it's unbelievable you know what i mean
i swear to god you get a woman in your
life she immediately becomes bum
phillips and you become earl campbell
you're gonna have a few good years but
when five she's gonna run you into the
[ __ ] ground
if you let her
um all right i got a little promotion
here uh
tim jones from one of my favorite bands
uh l.a bands but then even though
they're not la but the bands that i saw
here in la
from uh truth and salvage company which
i believe they might be on hiatus right
now
uh tim jones and
and uh what the [ __ ] did i read here
oh and this other musician named leroy i
couldn't figure out what his last name
were
who does all the all the wheeler walker
jr stuff they have a triple vinyl
startup release
going on right now i'll i'll send you
the link
um i guess they call it roots music i
just call it good music you should check
it out
um triple vinyl they made three albums
coming up of great music they have a
startup right now where you can uh go
out help
them out buy the albums and all that you
should check it out if you like truth
and salvage company this is one of the
dudes from them
uh from that band all right that was
probably one of the worst promos ever
tim if you hear this i apologize i'll do
a better
better job next time all right
okay that's it all right now with with
that
with that horrific promo let's talk
about this amazing
amazing douche i'm going to start a new
segment on here called amazing douche
and what's an amazing douche well i'll
tell you it's when you meet somebody
and they push through
being a douche just like the average
douche
you know like really you're gonna pass
me on the right on the [ __ ] highway
doing 80. it's kind of a [ __ ] but we'll
call them a douche just so this works
right
an amazing douche is such a
douche that that
you're not even mad at him you just
start watching you're
fascinated by the behavior like how
could you be that
big of a douche and not even be aware of
it
i mean that that is god damn that is
amazing
that there is an amazing douche there
did i explain it enough
so me and my wife um
we were driving around i can't remember
what the hell we were doing we're just
driving around
maybe trying to make my son go to sleep
or something
um so
we ended up going into uh this vegan
restaurant
all right it was funny we went in there
and i was all about i'm like all right
i've been eating
i think i ate a whole [ __ ] cougar
when i was mountain lion
i can't say cougar anymore right that
means some old broad trying to get some
dick there
um i ate a whole [ __ ] mountain lion
barbecued mountain lion when i was in uh
texas and i was like all right i
probably could use some sort of uh
salad here right some sort of greens
some sort of brussels sprouts or
whatever so i walk in there
and the second i walk in there's just
too many colors in there
you know what i mean like the menus just
too [ __ ] bright
too many pinks too many pastels and i'm
like i feel like i'm in a [ __ ] ice
cream
parlor right now and not a good one
either one of those
chain restaurant ones you know like
what's the one with all the different
flavors
those [ __ ] ice cream ones snake the
ones that had like nine million flavors
those things always suck the same way as
you go to a beer and it's like we
haven't
[ __ ] you go to a bar sorry you got a
bar we got 900 beers on tap oh do you
do you all right well i don't want to
get the one that nobody's [ __ ]
drinking that's just been sitting there
all stale actually
we run a bar it's been really difficult
during covert and just so you know
just so you know we make sure that
everything's a certain level of fresh or
else we go get another keg
sorry whatever i just never had you know
you're just trying to do too much so i
walk in there and i'm just like this is
one of these vegan places where people
think they're eating vegan and they are
but vegan is also eaten like potato
chips
right isn't it unless there's some some
sort of oil from a duck
that they fried it in but you know what
i mean it's like you it's one this is
one of these vegetarian places
where you eat there every day and then
you go to your therapist on thursday
every week or like i don't understand
why i'm such a fat [ __ ]
it's cause you're eating at a vegan
place with one of those [ __ ]
it's like a fast food place but it's
vegan right so we walk in there
and i forget what my wife ordered she
was some sort of
blt you know that wasn't wasn't bacon or
something right
and i go okay i'll get you that she goes
what are you getting and i was like i'm
not getting anything
she's like well you may not get anything
i thought you got to get something i was
just like i just don't like the color of
the menu
it's too uh it looks like cotton candy
the pink background and [ __ ] like what
are you trying to do here which
we all know when you go into a vegan
restaurant everything should be
green and brown they always have like
earth tones when you go in there and it
looks like the [ __ ]
bullwinkle show that's when i just start
going all right this is this isn't good
not saying the ones that have green
signs are good either
because god knows you know corporations
try to do that like they you know they
change their sides
like bp petroleum all of a sudden it
looks like are you guys selling corn
is this like a mom and pop farm i i
could have sworn you guys was
selling gas and oil here um
all right sorry i'm getting off the the
track here so
as i'm saying that the the guy in front
of us
the amazing douche with his girlfriend
right
or whatever whatever i hope it's just
his girlfriend i hope this
woman didn't marry this amazing douche
he's just doing
like you can't even believe the level of
small talk he's doing
you know it's just like so like how many
flavors i'm just so excited to be in
here right now this is like my
favorite restaurant like huh this is a
guy like what do you have like okay
could i get this
and could i get this sauce i just love
all your sauces can i get this too
what i'm trying to do is build like a
mountain of flavors here is what i'm
trying to do
he's just sitting there this is this is
a man talking
it sounded like you ever get behind a
couple of women checking into a hotel
if you're ever behind two women checking
into a hotel just immediately go to your
phone and start answering emails because
you're not going to talk to the person
behind the desk
for at least 12 minutes so what floor is
the gym on
now that breakfast is it a continental
breakfast it's just
okay it's just it's just continental you
okay with that yeah do you have a waffle
maker
you do you do have a waffle we shouldn't
do it like every day it's like maybe
like two days to do
okay what about the rooftop bar and they
just [ __ ] need to know everything
just get to you get a key go to your
room and shut your mouth
they don't do it they got a million
[ __ ] questions well this guy i wish i
understand
i understand why they do it see a man
has a clock
in his [ __ ] head there's only so long
i can keep going
or else somebody's gonna punch me in the
[ __ ] head they're gonna punch me in
the face because it's okay
if a woman gets punched in the face she
was she was assaulted
if i get punched in the face it just
means i got my ass kicked
so every guy has a clock in his head
going like i can only ask so many
[ __ ] questions
what floor is the gym on all right is it
a good gym
well yeah all right that means that
means it sucks all right thank you can i
have my keys and your
how late is room service you're saying
that as you're walking away from the
desk
you know or peripherally looking at the
person behind you making sure they're
not
going to punch you in the head even
though that never happened to me i think
that [ __ ] i think that [ __ ] when i'm at
an atm
and there's somebody behind me i gotta
get going
i gotta get going or this guy's gonna
punch me in the head i don't know
i don't know why i think that maybe
because i had an older brother i have no
idea
i [ __ ] drive out of a parking garage
i make sure i got that thing ready
ready to go stick the [ __ ] ticket in
i'm ready to go boom
light turns green i'm way out the
intersection ready to make a left
making sure not only the guy behind me
and the per the person behind me too is
going to make that light
all right sorry it's a lot of stress
so anyways this [ __ ] guy is acting
like a woman checking in at a hotel with
their best friend
okay and he said i'm just trying to
build like a mountain of flavors
you know because i'm like so excited and
the the [ __ ] look at my wife's face
looking at this guy
because it was just it what he wasn't
he wasn't that person he just knew that
it was fake that he was just
an ingratiating [ __ ] and he was just oh
my god
jesus i'm just so excited and what did
he say he goes this is like this is just
guilt-free eating
is something else you said
he looked like judge reinhold all right
and he was just
[ __ ] and he was a little mushy too
this is like guilt-free eating he just
kept running his
[ __ ] yap and it was just like would
you
just [ __ ] order and stand to the
right
and let progress happen
and he just kept talking and the only
thing that was keeping me sane
other than i'm learning to breathe
through times like this
is just looking at the look on my wife's
face
where she's just looking at this guy
like going you
phony full of [ __ ]
and what i'm not gonna say amazing
douche right
so then um
i don't know what he was still me my
wife when i go out but i order for my
wife then we sit down
and he goes back up to the counter he's
still running his yap
his girlfriend's barely talking right
occasionally she says something but you
can just see
like her life like how much this guy
is to deal with and that's that's saying
a lot coming from me
so he goes back up there and he just
goes i just want to say like you are you
are like
amazing i mean i mean i love this
restaurant i come in here all the time
and it's always amazing but it's never
been to like this level of awesomeness
right okay
so that's the guy he's pretending to be
and then the greatest thing happens is
my wife's order
comes out before his all right because
he ordered a mountain of flavor
right she just ordered the blt
and when the second it registers with
the amazing douche
that somebody behind him got their food
before him he
out loud is going like how come they got
their food before us i mean we were here
before them
immediately became that [ __ ] guy
that's right that's who the [ __ ] you are
not oh that all that other [ __ ]
mountain of flavor this level of
awesomeness you're just an ingratiating
[ __ ] and and and as we walked out i said
to my wife i was like did you hear that
did you hear him bitching
and she was like he said that i go yeah
like let me tell you something that's
who the [ __ ] that guy is what you just
saw right there
is the future head of a network
i was literally that's that right there
is what it's like to pitch a show hey
how are you this is so great we love
we love what you're doing we love what
you're doing on stage edgy we want edgy
let's push the boundaries let's push the
boundaries
and then you get in business with them
they're like does he really have to say
[ __ ] right here can he just say
woman well that's not who this guy is i
know but we have a lot of female viewers
what happened to the person in the
meeting
huh oh i got my order before you that's
what the [ __ ] you were a [ __ ]
ingratiating
maybe that's what it is ingratiating
[ __ ] amazing douche you know whatever
you want to call them
when they do the flip like an
oscar-winning performance you know
like what was what was the one uh ed
norton had back in the day
when he was this sweetheart of of a
young man and they were like how did
this guy do this blah blah blah and then
all of a sudden he just does
he does the flip in the end it's just
like whoa who is that
cold-hearted ice-cold lunatic
i don't know i don't know have i done
the same thing i don't know i think i
i am a consistent douche all right
which i don't have a problem with you're
a consistent douche you are who you are
i mean it's not fun to be around but you
know
listen as much as of an [ __ ] as i am
you'd never have to listen to me say a
mountain of flavor
or ever say this level of awesomeness
i will tell you this the woman behind
the counter was eating it up
she was vegan putty in his hand um
oh my god anyway plowing ahead let's
talk a little bit of football
[Music]
um oh i didn't talk oh billy redface i
was in the i'm in the mandalorian this
week
i forgot to bring that up all right
because they told me to keep my freckled
yap shut
until my episode came out so yes this
week
if you want to see uh if you want to see
my dumb head in the star wars uh
universe as they say
i am in episode i guess it's 15.
as far as the mandalorian ones and it's
as far as season two it's episode seven
so i am in that
and i want to thank everybody that
watched it and said all those nice
things about
my performance uh i want to thank rick
famous for
writing it and directing it and being
one of the
the great badasses i've ever met in this
business and john favreau and everybody
over there
all the actors i worked with everybody
everybody over there
um it's it's
it came out great i watched uh i watched
half of it my wife was watching it she
goes come on in here i was like i'm not
i'm not gonna watch this
and then i heard her laughing and
enjoying it and then there was one scene
i wanted to sit down to see how it came
out
this scene where i sit down with this
guy i used to work for my character used
to work for i just wanted to see how
that came out
um but i was very happy with it
so i want to thank those guys um
and everybody who said all the nice
things that you did that was pretty cool
not gonna lie it was very cool
all right let's talk football here um
where are we here oh my god i gotta talk
i didn't talk about this because it
happened on thursday
the new england patriots against the los
angeles rams
oh jesus oh jesus
oh jesus um
the new england patriots were trying to
do something that i don't know if any
team has ever done
and you only have the opportunity back
in the day you only had the opportunity
to do it in giant stadium or metlife
stadium whatever they say
whatever they call the patriots had the
opportunity
to win two games in the same stadium
against two different teams
within four days on the road
because they played the san diego
judges on sunday
absolutely destroyed him 45 to nothing
and then four days later we we didn't
even go home
we bill no the patriots didn't go home
said one of the saddest things about the
pandemic is i could have gone to back to
back patriots games in los angeles
they were playing your los angeles rams
four days later we we could uh
if we beat the rams i don't i was gonna
say i don't think that it
had ever happened that a road team won
two games in
four [ __ ] days against two different
teams while on the road
um you can only do it
in whatever the [ __ ] they're calling uh
the rams and chargers stadium and
whatever they call the giants jet
stadium now
we had the opportunity it was right
there and we got our asses
wet by the los angeles rams i mean we
could not do
anything offensively our our defense
played fine considering they were on the
field for like 75
of the game but jesus christ
we could not get anything going the rams
look great it did annoy me when i was
watching the game when they were trying
to say like well they got their
uh their revenge for the super bowl it's
like no you you know
why you don't do that to the rams
they're not satisfied with that they
want to win the super bowl
they're not just happy to beat the
patriots in [ __ ] december
what are you saying about your own team
and also not to mention
all [ __ ] nobody's so many people are
gone from that game anyways
it's a completely different patriots
team
you know i mean it's like if you're
beating the uh seattle seahawks now
that doesn't have all those same [ __ ]
people on it right marshawn lynch and
uh you know don't even throw it my way
if you throw it my way you're gonna have
problems whatever that guy's name was
who plays on the [ __ ]
uh 49ers now
um yeah it's it's a different team
all right anyway we got [ __ ]
destroy we got absolutely destroyed i
kind of just was watching that game
it's like one hand over my eye going
like wow
uh but we you know we do
we do have that that that white dude
with the blonde hair the polish kid
there whatever his name is
he seems to be uh you know there's
there's little
bright lights to the future um
i don't know we shall see but that that
was a tough one that was a tough one
um having said that i do really like our
uniforms
it's my favorite uniform the patriots
have had since they left the old pat
patriot one
now which to this day anytime they wear
that one in the throwbacks and i see
those
uniforms i have like heart palpitations
because it reminds me
of brutal losses in big games or getting
[ __ ] over on calls roughing the passer
against the oakland raiders who still
whine about the tuck rule
not realizing that was that that was
payback
for us getting [ __ ] the year that they
won the super bowl
all right so tell you what we'll give
you the two thousand
one [ __ ] super bowl trophy if you
give us the 1976 one how about that
we'll just we'll do an even swap
and even [ __ ] swap but knowing you
dirty bastards you probably didn't
polish your trophy
you can keep it um all right let's go
around
the league really quickly seattle
absolutely kills the new york jets one
of those games where you're like how in
the [ __ ] did i not bet the seattle
seahawks
going up against the hapless new york
jets
those poor bastards man i think i really
hate to say this but i think their
chance to win a game was against the
raiders
they're haters um what's going on with
the [ __ ]
the nfc east all of a sudden everybody's
winning
washington beat the 49ers but they're
injured eagles beat the uh drew
breesless
new orleans saints that's crazy
the buffalo bills
your buffalo bills beat the pittsburgh
steelers and i can tell you right now i
know that they're [ __ ] excited
right now in buffalo then i don't want
to be
a [ __ ] you know wet blanket on the
party out there but i when back when my
team was good last year
all the way back 20 years 20 straight
years i used to love losing games like
that
you want to lose the game to the team
you're then going to see in a month in
the playoffs
because for some reason then it flips so
uh i liked the steelers last night i
thought that they were going to win the
game
i'm a big ben roethlis roethlisberger
ross roethlisberger fan i came to say
his [ __ ] name
um you know my only complaint about the
steelers in the past is i feel like they
don't make halftime adjustments
it's like they come in this is what
we're doing and even if they're losing
they come out well we're still doing it
okay because we're the steelers okay
every 30 years we'll change a head coach
so we're not changing our game plan in
halftime they're just very they're still
it's a stoic
franchise but having said that they've
won six super bowls so you gotta respect
it
but the buffalo bills the buffalo bills
beat the pittsburgh steelers
to get it within a game the pittsburgh
steelers the
uh the chiefs keep on winning um they
there was a few things that were said
yesterday there's always a few things i
know that they're hyping up
you know certain aspects of it because
they got to sell the game but they're
like i've never seen an offense like the
kansas city chief i've never seen an
offense like this it's like yes you have
i have i've seen an offense like that
i've seen better offenses than that
throughout 40 years of watching football
stop acting like this is the greatest
[ __ ] offense you've been
i get it i'm going to watch the game
do i really have to go through all the
great [ __ ] offenses that i saw
really you think the kansas city chiefs
was better than [ __ ] dan marino mark
duper and mark clayton in [ __ ] 1984
where they absolutely shattered the
record books
back when you could beat the living [ __ ]
out of a [ __ ]
a [ __ ] wide receiver they didn't have
a running game
jesus christ better than john joe
montana and jerry rice with roger craig
better than that better than ronnie lot
and all those [ __ ]
hall of famers on defense giving joe the
ball back every third and out
never seen an offense like the kansas
city chiefs greatest show on turf
kurt warner holt and all of those guys
you know
uh uh marshall [ __ ] i never see the
three-headed monster
edgar and james peyton manning that guy
who may or may not have murdered
somebody
2008 the [ __ ] new england patriots
tom brady with all those weapons and
then they get randy moss
i've never seen an offense as great as
kansas city
jesus [ __ ] christ take it down a
little
it's [ __ ] insulting to anybody who's
watched the goddamn game for longer than
[ __ ]
18 months i've never seen an offense
like this
jesus christ terry bradshaw lin swan and
john stalworth he had two [ __ ] hall
of fame
you know i'm not saying tyreek hill
kelsey
and uh kevin von erick whatever they
have to think
hillel air or whatever the [ __ ] is name
clyde eugene abdul jabar whatever that
running back is i'm not saying they're
not doing great things but
the greatest offense you've ever seen
let's let's take it down a little bit
can you and not to mention
all of all the offenses that i just
mentioned were playing during a time
pre jim irsay in the nfl going well
we've reached maximum density as far as
sports fans
let's try to get the casual fan and make
even looking at a wide receiver pass
interference for a few years and if you
don't believe me with that
just look at the all-time uh
passing records and see how many active
quarterbacks slash quarterbacks who
played in the last 25 years
are in the top 20. and then go to
running backs running backs is
ridiculous you got frank gore
and um that guy who beat his kid with
that stick
used to play for the vikings i'm sorry
i'm not going with the game i'm not
going with the i'm not going with the
names but i'm good with the concert guy
well
they say maybe murdered somebody this
guy he beat his kid with the switch
um they're like in like the top
five and then it's just a total drop
off you don't see anybody else there's
like one or two guys
in like the top 30 rushing all time that
are still still active
because they just don't run the ball the
way they used to um
i actually think there's going to be
running backs that will
in the future have more receiving yards
than someone who was a questionable hall
of fame wide receiver
that's how much the game has changed
anyway and speaking of that
how much the game has changed i am so so
every year they got to bring up the 17-0
[ __ ]
miami dolphins the undefeated team
and that is such a stupid [ __ ]
it's like when are you going to just put
like an asterisk next to that
it's a 14-game season they only had to
win
17 games so nowadays for the pittsburgh
steelers
to have beaten the 72 dolphins to beat
their record they have to go
19-0 they have to win two more [ __ ]
games
do you remember the roger maris thing
when roger maris you know hit his 61st
home run or whatever and they put an
asterisk next to and everybody went oh
boohoo
they should have he played in more games
there were more games in the regular
season than there was
in uh you know when babe ruth played
i still think oj simpson in 1973 had the
greatest
year a running back has ever had where
he rushed for 2003 yards or whatever
in a 14-game season and now these kids
come along
they got 16 games to do what the [ __ ]
they did so this whole
you know 17-0 dolphins thing where i
just every year have to be like yeah if
they play two more extra regular season
games they automatically would have won
those
you know i don't know i don't know and
then also the fact that they
celebrate anybody who celebrates other
people losing
it's just like all right i don't know as
like a professional athlete to sit there
and root against people
because you just want to hold on to your
[ __ ] records that's not what old
people are supposed to do
you're supposed to encourage the next
generation you're supposed to want them
to be better than you because we're
human beings and we're incredibly flawed
right so take what i did that worked and
then you try and fix what didn't work
that's what you're supposed to do
um i don't know that would be like now
if somebody of a comedian got credit
cause
you know you've just broken george
carlin's record
for you know putting out hour-long
specials
um it's amazing i mean to just be in the
same sentence as
george carlin it's just like it's not
the same game george carlin
hbo like would have to would tell you
that they wanted like
you couldn't just say hey man i'm doing
a [ __ ] special
you didn't have all these streaming
platforms or you could just put it out
yourself
um there was only a handful of people
that that would even get special so the
fact that he did what he did
someone's gonna break the record um
i don't know sorry i'm just running my
yap i have i got a lot of [ __ ] to talk
about you know what i did i meditated
last night before i went to bed
because i'm really starting to believe
in this whole um
i don't know like i don't know what it
is i haven't even read about it i just i
just think you
damage your brain if you don't blow out
the lines every once in a while
meditate and get eight hours sleep the
stuff that people are talking about so i
actually downloaded an app
and um one of the great comedies you'll
ever see
is me downloading a meditation app
downloading something that's supposed to
help me relax
and then i get it and immediately it
asks me all of these
[ __ ] super [ __ ] intrusive
questions about how i found them out i
got to take a [ __ ] survey first like
this is making my blood pressure go up
and then i gotta create an account
and then once i get through all of that
[ __ ] [ __ ]
all right then i gotta listen to this
guy running his yap about his [ __ ]
past
and how he used to be a lunatic and he
did this and he did that
but i will give it up to this guy that
he kind of got to it quickly
and um
i don't know he was just sort of i was
able to like meditate and like make sure
that i got like
eight hours sleep because i knew i was
in a grumpy mood
because i started to watch a movie last
night that i've been trying to watch
this french movie which i
i highly recommend i'm watching it on
amazon
prime it's called uh
it's um i don't know how to say it it's
like uh profit
i don't know how to say it but in um
it's just a profit but you want to make
sure
you you watch this [ __ ] move but i'm
not gonna lie to you this is like
midnight express type of movie
where i watched the first half hour my
wife was just like all right
i'm kind of not in the mood for a movie
like this
so i was like all right so i just shut
it off but uh
[ __ ] incredible movie and we ended up
watching that thing about those poor
emaciated women trying to make the
[ __ ] dallas cowboys cheerleading team
jesus christ i don't think i've ever
seen
like how fragile
all of them you just see them every time
they come in like they'll be just okay
mandy okay everybody great routine mandy
you lagged behind a little bit
and they have to smile and be like
uh-huh okay
okay and then they go mandy why do you
think you suck today
well you know i just you know we didn't
have much time to to to learn the
routine and i just
okay yep and then they sit there and
they smile i know i know okay all right
i'm gonna work on that you guys gonna
see
yeah today was well to today was
definitely not my best performance
uh they do that and then they go off
into a corner
in the locker room and they cry
which i guess is a man i'm looking at
the wrong way they're actually getting
that emotion out of them so they can
not have it lingering in them and then
they can perform the next day but like
i don't know i was cracking my wife up
because
this woman was crying in the corner and
none of the other girls came over to
help her out
so one woman came over and put her arm
around her
and i was just saying all this [ __ ]
horrific [ __ ] that i get you know
you know i probably will get through
this just you know
one more thing then we'll make the team
and then we can both eat a dozen donuts
and puke behind a [ __ ] dumpster
and you know they were like emaciated
it's like they don't allow them you
can't eat
well i don't know i don't know what
they're doing i don't know what they're
doing but like
they were like twigs [ __ ]
there wasn't one thickie amongst them
and i was just like i don't know i
i don't know i don't know i just felt
bad for every one of them involved in
that [ __ ] thing
did you it's like they could just be
yeah you sucked you need to do this you
need to do that but to sit there and
they ask him
why do you think he sucked because they
want them to cry
so they have some sort of emotion on the
show
um i don't know and i'm just looking my
wife like how is this easier to watch
than this [ __ ] prison movie i was
watching
so he shanked a guy that's just an actor
that didn't really happen
this really happened to this woman's
hopes and dreams
[Laughter]
i don't think i'm ever going to get to
advertising this week i got such a good
night's sleep and
diarrhea of the mouth here um i saw
another clip right because i'm trying to
eat better
and uh like i said i ate an entire bison
when i was in texas and
uh and i enjoyed every delicious second
of it
texas is a fun place to get fat i'm
gonna tell you that right now
fun people out there um so
this person somebody sent me something
and it was this english guy coming out
talking about
um why we shouldn't eat animals
and basically brings up how his
he heard his dad screaming in agony as
he was dying in cancer
of can in cancer of cancer and his body
was just riddled with cancer and he was
like
screaming in agony like i don't know why
they didn't get him a tylenol or [ __ ]
some morphine or something but whatever
they went all natural right like those
chicks would give birth in a bathtub
right this guy went all natural with
this cancer
i don't know what he did but he was
screaming in agony
and uh he said when he went to a
slaughterhouse
he heard those same cries from the
animals
right and i was thinking like god damn
man that's
okay i get it point made
do i want to be a part of that right
and then you know because i always watch
animals fighting everybody i then see
polar bear eating a seal
alive and it's just
it's like they're doing it to each other
you watch like a praying mantis it just
grabs onto a hummingbird and just starts
eating its face
as the things [ __ ] please [ __ ]
fluttering trying to get the [ __ ] away
from it
but i guess because of religion
because we have egos i don't know does
any other animal have a [ __ ] ego
because they keep trying to attribute
all these human emotions
to uh animals like right down to sharks
like i've seen a few where they take
fish hooks out of these sharks and then
these sharks become
friends of these scuba divers or they're
feeding them and the sharks sort of
nuzzling its [ __ ] nose into the guy
like showing true affection i told you
that clip i saw it on instagram
on the on the gram gram there right in
the and then one of the scuba divers
trying to go like people really need to
stop
watching jaws and i and i want to be
like okay you kind of need to stop
watching doctor doolittle
because you're going to get your [ __ ]
arm bit off and then some poor [ __ ]
[ __ ]
not [ __ ] some poor guy in the coast
guard is gonna have to fly his
helicopter all the way out there to go
get you
you know put the floats on and risk his
[ __ ] life because your dumbass
was trying to live the courtship of
eddie's father with a [ __ ] bull shark
sorry old reference people let me tell
you about my best friend he's a
murdering
fish and all this stuff
tune in tonight for uh eddie and the
bull shark
surprising season ender eddie gets his
armpit off
but bully i thought we were friends
um all right sorry
so uh and then they show like you know
people like saying pigs are smarter than
dogs
which i'm totally fine with and i love
dogs i like the dogs have a certain
level
of dumbness you know that you come home
and they're always excited they're too
stupid
to realize that you coming home is not
an amazing thing this is where you live
you know then you leave and then they
[ __ ] freak out every time i god
was that it did he just walk out of my
life oh my god he's hot
yes yes you rock i like you know
i'm gonna get a [ __ ] pig and then the
pig's gonna be like all right dude i'll
see you later
like some [ __ ] roommate that i used
to have that when i would come home i'd
hope he wasn't there so i could have
[ __ ] moments of peace
i don't need that out of an animal i
needed an animal is there
to build up my my self-esteem
sorry so i was really like buying into
this [ __ ] and then i just see the stuff
that animals do to other animals
you know the best argument that i saw
for going like uh
vegetarian or going more vegetarian is
just like
all the cattle out there farting into
the atmosphere
it's like bad for the environment or
something like that to keep us all alive
but then my daughter said the other day
was she was like
she's like dada she goes what is
your favorite dinner and i i had i was
like a cheeseburger it's got to be a
cheeseburger
if i could eat one of those every day
and not get fat i would
i would i would even put it you know
it's cheeseburger or a pizza
it's just something that i can
consistently eat and not get
sick of it oh my daughter said something
so
[ __ ] hilarious the other day she said
you know they just like they learn
expressions and then they want to try
them out
oh [ __ ] i already forgot what she said
she goes dad she goes i got some good
news
oh she goes dad i got good news i got
some good news
and some bad news so i'm already
laughing like where the hell did she
learn this
and i go all right what's the good news
and she goes
she goes the good news is i tell jokes
like you
and i was like that's great i go what's
the bad news
she goes the bad news is dada you play
too rough with me
she keeps saying her foot hurt i think
one time
i don't know what i did stepped on her
foot when we were playing i was spinning
around her foot in a table or something
like that
so now her foot doesn't hurt anymore but
she always says that it still hurts
like guilting me like your foot doesn't
hurt
and then she laughs and goes yes it does
because you play too rough
and it's because what happened i don't
even remember probably a few months ago
i was playing too
rough or whatever you know
she hurt her foot and then my wife
probably gave me [ __ ] and said you're
playing too rough with her and then she
got that expression stuck in her head
and now i'm [ __ ] sitting on my head
going like wait a minute is her foot
really hurt
then it isn't because i do little tests
with her you know we watching tv and i
just sort of rub her foot
add a little more pressure and she
doesn't complain about it so i'm like
all right your foot isn't hurt
you're just repeating stuff that mom
said all right so now i'm the bad guy is
that what it is
is that what we're trying to say here um
nba basketball is already back so my
question
as a sports fan is where is the hockey
how is hoop already back in hockey isn't
oh that's right
hockey's a man game all right here he
comes down the lane to dunk the ball
and everybody clears out so they don't
end up on instagram
holy [ __ ] is he the next michael jordan
all right let's do a little bit of
advertising here hello hello oh
hello fresh
hellofresh delivers fresh high quality
pre-portioned ingredients
so you can make meals that are delicious
and nutritious
over 90 percent of ingredients are
sourced directly from growers
to ensure peak flavor and ripeness hello
fresh hello newman hellofresh is the
first global carbon neutral
meal kit company great value
say 40 percent when you use hello fresh
versus shopping at the grocery store by
skipping the grocery store and using
hello
fresh you're reducing your food waste by
at least
25 that's amazing because my thing with
these is then they always come in those
little
um containers what do you do with the
containers are they recyclable
uh easily change your delivery days or
meal plan
preferences and skip a week whenever you
need
uh right on the app keep the fridge
stocked by adding extra meals or
additional proteins
quick meals like breakfast on the go or
their 10-minute lunches
and even desserts to satisfy that sweet
tooth
hello fresh is committed to donating
um to those in need so far in 2020
they've donated 3.5
million meals that's great helping out
your fellow man
and woman and days and
whatever else you're supposed to say
hello fresh offers convenient
no contact delivery to your doorstep for
easy home cooking with the family
it always should have been no contact
you got my food
uh go to hello fresh slash eight
zero burr and use the code 80 burr
to get eighty dollars off including free
shipping
that's hello fresh dot com slash
eight zero burr b u r r code eighty bur
for eighty dollars off and free shipping
policy genius you know the holiday
season whoopee dooby doo sure knows how
to lighten your wallet
for many families decembers december is
one of the most expensive months of the
year
not to mention the busiest if you're
looking for a fast and easy way to put
some money back in your pocket
why not reshop your home and auto
insurance rates with policy genius
policy genius combines a cutting edge
insurance marketplace
with help from licensing somebody sat
down
and created a cutting edge insurance
rate
program good
lord the amount of people out there that
think they're [ __ ] smart you know
what i mean
because they read things can you do that
how the how the [ __ ] do you learn how to
do something like that policy genius
combines a cutting edge insurance
marketplace
with help from licensed experts to save
their home and auto insurance an
average of one thousand dollars per year
better yet
it's really simple to use first head to
policygenius.com and answer a few quick
questions about yourself and your
property
then policy genius does the rest they'll
compare rates from over 30 top insurers
from progressive
to nationwide is on your side
to find the lowest quotes their license
experts will look at all the ways to
maximize your savings including
building your home and auto policies if
policy genius finds a better rate then
god damn it
what you're doing what you're currently
paying then god damn it you'll they'll
they'll get you switched
for free that for free
right no divorce settlement you just
leave them
to go to them that kind of service has
earned policy genius a five-star rating
across the six
across over 1600 reviews of trust pilot
in google so if you're feeling the pinch
during the
holiday season find out how much you
could have saved on home and auto
insurance at policygenius.com
they've saved the home and auto
insurance customers an average of one
thousand dollars a year
by reshopping policy genius um when it
comes to insurance
it's nice to get it right oh look what
we got
look who we got we got two more
everybody
all right we're we're coming around the
clubhouse turn here are we
down the back stretch i don't know
indochino
you know the end of the year is the
perfect time to revamp your wardrobe
out with the old in with the new and
take your roll don't take it to goodwill
take it right to a tent city
give those people those clothes because
they'll wear all of them
you know because who's kidding who you
go down to goodwill
you don't bring them your good stuff you
bring them your mistakes so take your
old mistakes
the [ __ ] you bought this year give it to
homeless people
all right and then you wear the new
indochino stuff when you stop at the red
light
and you look at the homeless person
right
you'll have a big smile on your face and
they'll think oh my god he has a heart
he's going to give me change
and you're really just sitting there
going like i can't believe i [ __ ]
wore that shirt
what an idiot and then the light turns
green you drive off without giving them
a quarter
with indochino uh perfectly fitted
custom clothes are more affordable than
you might think
and your stylish friend and for your
stylish friend
what are they trying to say there
is that code is he gay this is my
stylish friend
i like that i'm gonna start saying that
this is my stylish friend uh and for
your stylish friend pick up a gift card
this is not forget gay guys do not shop
at [ __ ] indochino
i don't know where they shop but the
style's a little heightened than that
don't they this is for this is for your
metrosexual look i don't want to cut gay
guys out of this
okay i want to be inclusive all right
then for your stylish friend
wink wink pick up a gift card for a
present you won't need to keep
a gift receipt for talk about how you
feel
when you find clothing that fits you and
your style just right i feel like a
million bucks
i don't feel fat i feel confident to
walk up to the bar
you know order a
[ __ ] sarsaparilla i can't even drink
anymore i don't know what i don't know
what i feel like
i feel good about myself okay there
indochino you brought it out of me
uh do you feel more confident like
you're expressing yourself more fully
or that you stand out from the crowd no
i just don't i just happy i
feel like i look like less of a douche i
like the bar is set really low
all right new year new you
yeah why don't you guys order this [ __ ]
and all of a sudden you'll be called a
stylish friend
uh new year new you calls for a wardrobe
that fits you perfectly indochino
is here to help you start 2021 with made
to measure
custom clothing at a more affordable
price you can also give a gift card
you can give the gift of the perfect
custom fit
let me try that again you can also give
the gift of the perfect custom fit with
an indochino gift card
offers completely custom fit suits like
cam newton right
coats and casual wear at surprisingly
affordable prices i think cham newton
goes to indochino
uh customize everything from the fabric
and lining to the lapel
shape and monogram the choice is yours
and since your order is made to your
exact measurements
each piece will fit you and your style
perfectly
the best part indochino suits start at
just 299
with all customizations included book a
virtual appointment and shop online at
indochino.com and right now
you'll get 30 off any purchases of 399
or more when you enter the code bur at
checkout that's 30
off a purchase of 3.99 or more 399
or more at indochino.com
i-n-d-o-c-h-i-n-o
dot-com promo code burr b-u-r-r oh
the last one last one
it's the last one to reheat
hymns for hymns
why do guys turn to weird solution or do
nothing when they
can turn to medic medicine and science
i don't know we're talking about covid
uh solution for hims.com a one-stop shop
for hair loss
skin care sexual wellness for men look
at that you get an indochino suit
and then you make sure your dick works
your hair's all wavy
right your skin is clear
walking up looking like [ __ ] james
spader
back in the day sorry my wife was
watching pretty in pink
yesterday i've still never seen that
i've never just sat down and watched
that movie i've seen bits and pieces of
it
i know there's andrew mccarthy there's
ducky
the guy from the show with uh jonathan
cryer
is hiding out jonathan cryer
molly ringwald
and uh somebody else i forget who else
i've never i don't know why
and i always say the same thing i go is
this fresh horses
she goes no it's pretty in pink every
single time all right it's time to write
a new chapter
one in which you have hair um no snake
oil pills or gas station counter
supplements prescription solutions
backed by
scientists what science what do you do
if i got this and i got my hair back
right i just grew it out like matthew
mcconaughey uh hims was created by a guy
who knows some health men's health
conversations
are easier online than in person no more
awkward in person
doctor's visits yeah yeah my dick
doesn't work
i'm losing my hair and i don't feel like
chicks want to bang you don't want to
say that to another man
or maybe you do maybe you do sit there
and you look him in the eye
make him feel uncomfortable or long
pharmacy lines
for hymns connects you to licensed
medical professionals online
which could save you hours completely
confident and discreet
answer a few quick questions a medical
professional will review and if they
determine it's right for you you can
prescribe your medic
medications to treat hair loss that is
shipped directly to your door
today hymns is giving you the best offer
yet
if you're not happy with your results
after 90 days hymns
will give you a full refund and right
now my listeners can get their first
visit absolutely free go to for hims.com
bird that's for hims.com
bird disclaimer must include all right
prescription pro i gotta read it first
prescription products require an online
consultation with the health care
provider who will determine if the
prescription is appropriate restrictions
apply see the website for full details
and important safety information
remember that's for hims.com
f-o-r-h-i-m-s dot com slash
bird b-u-r-r-e-d
all right let's get to the questions
everybody oh my goodness
i'm in such a good got enough sleep mode
i'm actually going to play my jingle
right
it's time for advice hey
that's me from somebody
else all right let's do it
let's let's all go to the lobby all
right
hey space shoulder
space shoulder uh hey there billy bespin
props to the special effects team
who was able to cgi your shoulder
movement
he's talking about the mandalorian i
turned to my wife and i said
see that extension not bill not bill at
all
i'll have you know my shoulders feel
great and i did it all naturally
i took a year i started off by doing
curls with my toothbrush
i've now built it up to uh four pounders
i'm actually
up into um purple
you know why do weights shame you if you
do the one pounders they're pink
then you move up to purple then it
gradually they'll go to more like you
know i can handle myself in a situation
man colors
you know you get into the browns and the
beiges before it just goes
black right all right 1970s movies
dear billy burning bush
you know it never ceases to amaze me all
of these years you guys still figure out
a new way to [ __ ] make fun of me i
really appreciate it
i'm not even joking you give me a laugh
every week so thank you all right
big fan from columbus
ohio uh name is jared if you want to
read it out loud and make my buddies go
ape [ __ ] all right i read it because
you'd be one
evidently you don't have any [ __ ]
skeletons in your closet here
all right love both your comedy and the
podcast especially when featuring the
lovely nia
uh i know you've been burning through
70s flicks
and i'm somewhat of a movie encyclopedia
so i decided to weaponize my
autism for your viewing pleasure all
right
goodfellas is one of my all-time
favorites and the nice guys
was the best movie of 2016. i loved that
[ __ ] movie
so i think our tastes are at least
mildly compatible
uh here are a few recommendations i'll
try to spare you
the super well-known ones oh dude
there's nothing better than a great
obscure
movie band
uh football player whatever anything
obscure
that's actually good nobody knows about
it is the [ __ ] all right
sorcerer 1977. you guys should write
these down here man
uh the most underrated movie in cinema
history action-packed thriller by
uh willian friedkin
wilhelm friedkin the same dude who made
the exorcist and the french connection
two of my other favorites
well [ __ ] i gotta watch that
deep red no that's not about a smarter
version of me
thank you uh 1975 ultra
violent murder mystery by dario argento
or argento who also made the horror
classic
sespira suspiria two years later
another awesome one haven't seen that
one either i'm watching all of these
duel 1971 early stephen spielberg flick
low budget road thriller with some great
car chases i gotta check that one out i
love spielberg
all right black christmas 1974
the absolute scariest slasher movie i've
ever seen
perfect for morbid holiday watching if
you're a blasphemous bastard like me
dark star dude dark star 1974
goofy-ass sci-fi comedy by john
carpenter
who would go on to do other goofy
classics like big trouble in little
china
great [ __ ] movie 1986 [ __ ]
hysterical
um that's god what's his face in it
kurt russell my favorite thing is when
he delivers that line and then
exaggerate like bites into that sandwich
uh big trouble in little china is great
all right the tenant
and also so on point to make fun of
those kinds of movies as they were still
coming out
and people weren't making fun of the
action hero movies uh the tenant 1976
early polanski guy's a freak but christ
can he make a movie
uh mind [ __ ] of a paranoia story about
a man
slowly going insane while shut away in
an apartment
something we can currently understand
wow dude i don't like
i don't like scary movies man i'm not
into like i take the ride
they scare the [ __ ] out of me and they
stay with me and i start walking in
to places here in babadook
um la samar the samurai la samarie
1967. it's a bit earlier than the ones
you're looking for but i also know
you're learning french so
two birds one stone super badass
assassin thriller
with a jazzy soundtrack oh my god that's
got it
even gets into my drum and [ __ ] uh sorry
if i wasted your time with a bunch of
movies you've seen i haven't seen any of
those i've tried to give you
some obscure ones that i really really
like stay
safe and get your lovely co-host back on
the podcast soon i
am i'm getting some microphones i'm
updating my little studio here
i've already ordered them i'm just
waiting for them to come and i'm gonna
have there's gonna be more
nia in 2021 um
also you know i think we've stumbled
upon another cool thing here
um let's you know anything obscure
top 10 obscure cars top 10 obscure
albums
uh if you want to say your obscure
movies the ones that you know that
people should [ __ ] see and they they
never do
all right um let's see here french
movies hey billy
ball buster hey billy billy ball buster
all right love the podcast i always
wanted to learn french also but all my
friends convinced me that french
that the french are [ __ ] like we're
not everybody's [ __ ]
and so are they but then when you go
over there you get to act like an
[ __ ] american and then hear an
[ __ ] french guy talking about you
in his native language and then you get
to be like i know what the [ __ ] you
saying
and watch his little [ __ ] little
pocket square fall out of his
jacket um anyway i might take it up
again after
hearing of your success yeah i'm moving
right along
uh francais
patribian volleyball
i'm not learning a lot of those um
my favorite french word right now is
boulevard boulevard
um and everybody thinks that like french
is like really like effeminate and all
that [ __ ]
and i would just say go watch
any movie with that dude from the
professional who i should know his name
he's like like french the french
language is actually when it's spoken
by some street thug actory dude in a
movie
is one of the coolest [ __ ] sounded
language it's just like you know
you have that stupid when you make fun
of the english accent oh you know
and then you watch one of their gangster
movies you're like oh man that sounds
[ __ ] cool as [ __ ]
so basically every language sounds cool
if it's a if there's a badass speaking
it
you know what i mean you just gotta find
the movies
all right uh french movies all right um
i heard you say you wanted
some more french movies i have three for
you
i don't know emily i don't have to say
it ame
with the accent coming back at you like
you're smoothing your hair that's how i
remember it and the other one is your
brother's slapping you off the top of
the head
excellent hey ooh x i think that's
accent grav
um a-m-e-l-i-e
cute movie about a daughter finding her
place in the world
well maybe i could watch that with my
daughter um city of lost children
a slightly weird movie starring ron
perlman
i love ron perlman uh marquis
mark marcus marquis m-a-r-q-u-i-s
uh this one i found at the local video
store in high school
in the foreign section i bought the vhs
off ebay about 10 years ago
this is a cinephile here but haven't
seen it anywhere else good luck it's
weird
hope you get to check out these and the
fashions
the fashion of the letters and in the
fashion of the letters
i don't know what that means all right
i'll check those out
all right the british have the worst
taste in tea oh my god
shots fired hey billy bullocks greetings
from ireland
i have to say first i absolutely love
the show it used to be the highest of my
week
when i was in the office and now it's oh
my god you know we were we were talking
about winston churchill
me and burke christ were on the billbert
podcast just saying how that dude was a
man the way he stood up to the nazis
and some dude [ __ ] said you should
look at his difficult relate
it's it it said winston churchill then
he wrote educate yourself
and it's his complicated history with
the irish
and just saying educate yourself as a
human being to another human being like
that guy right then it was just like
i don't ever need to meet this person in
life i know exactly this that is one of
the most
self-satisfying
[ __ ] persons people you could ever
[ __ ] meet in your life
all right you know everything i'll try
to i'll try to come up onto your [ __ ]
plane
you know not check out check out this
you know just to sort of balance out
educate yourself in other words i know
who winston churchill
is even though i've never met him
and you don't all right i have i have to
say first
i absolutely love the show i used to be
the highest
it used to be the highest highlight of
my week
when i was in the office and now it's
even more so during lockdown and working
from home it really cheers me up
love hearing stories about growing up in
boston it sounds very much like growing
up here in ireland
i don't know how many times i've been
called to [ __ ] marry for the
slightest of things by an adult
as a kid uh but every everyone rips on
each other
it's more of a term of endearment than
anything and it toughens you up
yeah it absolutely is um oh and by the
way next if it's done right
if it's done right it can also be
something that tries to build you down
and then you spend years trying to
figure out who you are and building
yourself back up again but that's a
different story
oh and by the way next time you're over
here hopefully when all this craziness
gets back to normal uh there's more to
ireland than just
dublin please if you can do some gigs
and what are you talking about i've done
gigs
in cork city or galway i did gigs in
galway i've gone up to belfast
i've i've done uh kill kenny i only did
it once but i've been over i've been
around
[ __ ] with you huh face down in a
guinness
we don't drink guinness over here that's
the [ __ ] we expo
go [ __ ] yourself uh please if you can
try
doing some gigs in cork city or galway
you won't be disappointed both cities
have a much better audience than those
superior dubs
oh you're all insecure because they live
in the big city
who they think who think they're the
bees knees
oh yeah i went to galway i found out
about all those babies you threw down
that [ __ ] wealth for those chicks who
got knocked up out of wedlock yeah it
was
it's a beautiful seaport city
that was one of the best sets i've ever
had i just kept referencing that there
was some sort of [ __ ] thing over
there where these chicks who would get
knocked up who weren't married
they'd be sent away in shame to this
nun convent or something like that and
they'd give birth and sometimes the
babies would die and there'd be no
record that the baby even
lived and they just stuck them into like
their segment tank or some [ __ ]
and then one day it backed up and they
were cleaning the well out or whatever
the [ __ ] it was and all of a sudden
there was all these dead babies down
there
it's [ __ ] unbelie religion i swear to
god
even though i'm starting to believe more
in an afterlife again that there is
something beyond this religion has no
idea what it is or even understands
i don't think they even understand god i
don't because what they say god is and
what i'm seeing out here
to just use the devil as a scapegoat is
really just
more like you just don't [ __ ]
understand like i do nobody understands
what's what's going
on why the [ __ ] we're here or what the
meaning of all of this is
all right all right let's plow ahead
here anyway anyhow
i see you're getting into drinking tea
no i'm not i'm not going to drink tea i
just [ __ ]
drink that throw coat [ __ ] so i
preserved my instrument
sorry um as you probably know from your
cigar smoking you want something that's
quality the english
have this worldwide reputation for their
tea drinking
from t tv and movies i reckon but
their tea tastes like cat pissed
especially that earl grey
shite uh i i'm some family living over
there so i've tried them all and haven't
found anything good is
that's even worse anything as good as
even the worst brands of tea back here
look at the irish talking [ __ ] here
you thought we were just [ __ ] all
about uh
[ __ ] booze and wearing those sweaters
whether a jumper whatever the [ __ ] they
call them
forget what they call uh if you can
source some irish tea
there's some irish stores over there
that stalk
stock it i'll i'll even send you some if
that's possible somehow
what you need to get your hands on is
the pinnacle of irish tea
called barry's tea oh my god
i gotta get some of that [ __ ] there's
nothing else like it trust me it's a
real gem
lions tea is fairly good options too
l-y-o-n-s
um if that's all you can get a hold of
advice on making it
you may be doing this already but boil
the kettle and just
before it's about to finish boiling
cut off cut it off and the tea bag goes
in the cup
first then pour the hot water over it
and leave it don't touch it don't stir
just walk away for about a minute and a
half
come back take the tea bag out now you
can give it a little stir
i this is great great advice i haven't
heard you mention this before but please
add a drop of milk
um not a lot just a drop and stir
some stir some more
and that it your tea and oh he
spelled check here and that it your tea
is ready i guess and then your tea is
ready
uh p.s blow on the tea first and sip to
make sure the temperature is good
dude if it's boiling i'm waiting more
than a minute and a half that's my
biggest problem with tea is it [ __ ]
burns the inside of my mouth if you
drive dive straight in you're gonna burn
your taste buds
and not be able to taste anything for a
few days which sucks as you probably
already know
best regards and happy christmas merry
christmas
happy holidays not happy christmas to
yourself me and the two little ones hope
you have a wonderful day that's great
advice barry's tea everybody
all right we're gonna wrap it up here
with uh
dumb questions for employees this is for
you guys who haven't listened in a few
weeks we've been you know people working
with the general public
and people tend to come in and ask dumb
questions and the classic one was myself
who went to the joshua tree
and asked the first park ranger where he
saw where is the joshua tree
not realizing that joshua tree was a a
species of tree
like it would be on the east coast being
like where is the
elm tree um
dumb question for employees antarctica
listener
hey old billy boy i was listening to
your monday morning podcast and heard
your call out for listeners in
antarctica while i'm not there at the
moment i'm currently in training
to head down for the next 12 or so
months
with the australian antarctica program
for what will be my third season as a
carpenter
what the [ __ ] are you building down
there global warming right australia's
on fire antarctica is sort of shaped
like it it's surrounded by water
good good for you guys i love it take it
over
uh while on the ice my job is to
maintain the station
assisting with any science projects and
generally helping out the station
um in the kitchen etc whenever i tell
anyone i work down there
about 90 of the people's first question
is whether i see any polar bears
i just politely say that there wouldn't
be any penguins
if there were uh here are a few other
stupid questions
i've had over the years
number one when talking to conspiracy
theorists whack jobs i've been asked if
i've seen the ice wall
or crashed ufos
then been called a liar or government
shill when they don't get the answer
they want what is the ice wall
oh my god is that when they think that
we you know
the world is flat we live in a giant
cereal bowl ice wall
conspiracy
and our i can't spell this antarctica
ice wall ice wall may refer to the wall
of ice
they refer to ice wall any wall of ice
flat earthers crews will sail to
antarctica
ice wall
all right let's see here organizers of
the annual conference that brings
together people who believe that the
earth
is flat are planning to cruise to the
purported edge of the planet
they're looking for the ice wall that
holds back the oceans
the journey will take place in 2020 the
fl
oh my god somebody has to film that
somebody has got to film that that is
amazing
that is amazing that's that's that's
planet planet of the eights when he's
gonna come around and [ __ ] see
that statue of liberty laying there in
half i wanna say that
i will actually contribute money to that
journey
um okay dumb question number two
do you all stay in igloos oh jesus
number three uh when telling an
apprentice at work i was going to
antarctica
he replies that's up in alaska isn't it
oh jesus anyways love the podcast mate
listening to you read out loud and
ranting about the world we live in is a
great way to pass time
on the station and on the two-week trip
to the
the icebreaker takes getting either
there or back
all the best to me and the family and go
[ __ ] yourself man that must be really
peaceful though
if you're just out there and there's no
internet or [ __ ] like that and just be
on that boat
that would be amazing i think i would
feel way better if i was going back to
australia rather than to antarctica even
though i would be excited
but in my head it'd be like oh my god am
i going to run into the thing down here
or was that the north pole did i just
ask a dumb question all right
furniture mover hey billy brady blower
uh come on you can't i'm not blowing the
guy i'm just saying what he's doing
uh he they won again yesterday i used to
work as a furniture mover in south
south texas san antonio about 15 years
ago
and we would always get dumb ass
questions by customers
but these are my top five furniture
mover
top five dumb questions number five
i guess you don't need a gym membership
do you answer
no you [ __ ] i get paid [ __ ] every day
for the benefit of fitness
response only if you tip
oh okay that's what you say all right
but you want to say the other thing okay
um do i tip you
answer well you tipped your pizza guy
five dollars before checking to see if
he delivered your ten dollar pizza right
i took your five 5 000 tv across the
[ __ ]
county lines and i'm on probation and
didn't steal it so you tell me if i
deserve a tip
all right number three can you gu
can you and your guys take your shoes
off when you come in and out
answer no the cleaning guy will charge
you more
if me or my guy slips on your floor
while you're carrying a couch
and bleed out
um do you guys do plants
it happens all the time you wouldn't
believe i don't even know what that
means
answer i'll move it but i'm not a
gardener
uh [ __ ] oh they want you to dig up a
plant i thought they meant like a house
plant
if [ __ ] goes bad ask my cousin uh
cousin he's illegal and your new
neighbor
i don't know what that means an illegal
immigrant number one
will all this fit on in one trip
and 85 dollars an hour
two hour quote third okay wait wait wait
wait
we'll all will all this fit in one trip
and it says
and eighty five dollars an hour two hour
quote
third floor walk up apartment answer
ma'am this is a moving truck
you've been pack renting for 20 years in
this home
and considering that you have a
billboard comedy central vhs tape
i would say no more than one trip
thanks a lot bill and can't wait to see
you in texas oh that one was from a
while ago i already did the uh
i already did the tour there all right
everybody thank you so much for
listening to this podcast look at this
here i did an hour and 20 minutes
because i got a good night's sleep
um i'm back into it i'm back into
getting sleep taking naps
and meditating let's see how long this
lasts this is like i'm going to the gym
i'm getting my abs i'm going to take
care of my brain
all right go [ __ ] yourselves everyone
thank you to everybody that watched the
mandalorians said all those amazingly
nice things
thank you once again to rick famaiwa and
uh john favreau for uh
writing it directing it that's rick and
john for putting me in it
editing it and doing all that stuff uh
amazing to be a part of that
all right and with that go [ __ ]
yourselves and i'll check in on you on
thursday oh by the way cleveland browns
tonight
i love seeing the browns being good you
know but i got a sneaking suspicion
the ravens are upset lamar jackson's
like hey wait a minute i thought i was
one of the best guys in the league and
now everybody's [ __ ]
talking about other people maybe i have
to go off tonight we will see what
happens it's in baltimore i believe
that's it i'll see you thursday